the Joe Rogan experience now you're in
the middle of this this strange time
where you're selling your houses you say
you don't want any material possessions
and have been seen all that and I've
been really excited to talk to you about
this yeah because it's an interesting
thing to come from a guy like yourself
like why are you doing that I'm slightly
sad about it actually
but what if you're sad about it why are
you doing it I think I make possessions
kind of weigh you down then they're kind
of an attack vector
you know you'll say hey billionaire you
got all this stuff like no I'm done our
stuff now what are you gonna do attack
vector meaning like people targeted yeah
mmm interesting yeah but you're
obviously gonna so you're gonna rent a
place yeah okay and get rid of
everything except clothes no I said like
almost everything so it's like keep a
couple Tesla's yeah shows house kind of
have to yeah that's the product and
stuff um yeah there's things that have
sentimental value for sure keeping those
yeah yeah so do you feel like is what's
worse think it'd happen yeah you're fine
yeah yeah you could always buy more
stuff if you don't like it though yeah I
mean from the money that you sell all
your stuff you could buy new stuff but
do you feel like people define you by
the fact that you're you're wealthy and
that they define you in a pejorative way
for sure I mean not on your own but
right you know there's for sure in
recent like you wrote years billionaire
has become a purge ah you like it's in a
pejorative like it's like that's a bad
thing which I mean I think don't doesn't
make a lot lot of sense in most cases if
you if you've done if you basically
organized the company like what's like
kind of how does this wealth arise it's
if you organize people in a in a better
way to produce products and services
that are better than what existed before
and you have some ownership in that
company
then that that essentially gives you the
right to allocate more capital so it is
it's that there's a conflation of
consumption and capital allocation so
let me say Warren Buffett for example
Andrea totally Frank I'm not his biggest
fan but I know he does like capital
allocation and he reads a lot a lot of
sort of annual reports of companies and
what will be counting and it's pretty
boring really
and he's trying to figure out is he does
Coke or Pepsi deserve more capital I
mean that's I mean it's kind of a boring
job if you ask me but you know it's
still a thing that's important to figure
out like which it is a company deserving
of more or less capital should that
company grow or expand is it making
products and services that are better
than others or worse and you know should
you know if we kind of a company is
making compelling parts and services it
should get more capital and if it's not
it should get less well got a business
well there's a big difference - between
someone who's making an incredible
amount of money designing and
engineering fantastic products versus
someone who's making an incredible
amount of money by investing in
companies or moving money around the
stock market or doing things along those
lines it's it's a different thing and to
put them all in the same category seems
it's it's very simple and as you pointed
out it's an attack vector
yeah for sure I mean I think it's really
I I do think there in the in the United
States especially there's an over
allocation of talent in finance and law
basically to many smart people go into
finance and law so you know this is both
a compliment and a criticism we should
have I think fewer people doing law and
your people are doing finance and more
people making stuff yeah yeah well that
would certainly be better for all
involved if they made better stuff yeah
yeah absolutely
and and you know manufacturing used to
be highly valued and
the United States and these days it's
not it's it's often looked down upon
which i think is wrong
yeah well I think that people are kind
of learning that particularly because of
this whole pandemic in this relationship
that we have with China that there's a
lot of value in to making things into
making things here yes somebody's got to
do the real work
yeah you know and you know like making
making a car at Solano stays as honest
day's living that's for sure you know or
making anything really or providing a
valuable service like providing you know
good or entertainment get information
that these are all valuable things to do
you know so yeah the trip should be more
more of it did you have a moment where
is this something that this idea of
getting rid of your material possessions
is something that built up over time or
did you have a moment of realization
where you realize that yeah I've been
thinking about it for a while you know
part of it is like I like I have a bunch
of houses but I don't spend a lot of
time in most of them and that doesn't
seem like a good use of assets like
somebody could probably be enjoying
those houses and get better even than me
so don't you have Gene Wilder's house I
do that's amazing it's awesome Wow yes
it's exactly what he's expected did you
request that the buyer not [ __ ] it up
yeah that's a requirement requirement
that's a good requirement yeah not in
that case in that house yeah it'll
probably self last but still I don't
care he's a legend you want his soul
you'd want his essence yeah in the
building it's and it's there that's a
real quick is it quick yes yeah what
what makes you say it's there look what
do you get out of it I mean all the all
the cabinets are like can't handmade and
they're like odd shapes and there's like
doors to nowhere and strange like
corridors and tunnels and really odd odd
paintings on the wall and yeah did you
ever live in it it's very clear
I did live in it briefly yeah but why do
you buy houses like if you own all these
houses do you just get bored and go I
think I'd like to have that well I you
know had one house and then the gene
Wilder house right across the road from
me from from my main house and it was
gonna get it was gonna get sold and then
torn down and turned into you know be a
big construction zone for three years
and I was like well I think I'll buy it
and preserve the spirit of gene water
and not have a giant construction zone
and then the you know I start having
like some privacy issues where like
people would like less people I come to
my house and you know start climbing
over the walls and stuff don't hate man
so then I started like what a house some
of the houses around my house and then I
thought at one point well you know it'd
be cool to to build a house so I
acquired some properties at the top of
Samara Road and which has got a great
view and it's like okay well these some
bunch of sort of small older houses
they're gonna get torn down anyway I was
like well you know like collect these
like little little houses then I can
build something you know I don't know
artistic like a you know dream house
type of thing what's a dream house for
Elon Musk like some Tony Stark type [ __ ]
yeah definitely yeah you gotta have the
dome that opens up with the stealth
helicopter and that kind of thing you
know yeah for sure [ __ ] yeah yeah okay
but but then I was like man Doralee what
it doesn't really make sense for me to
spend time designing and building a
house and I'd be real you know get like
OCD on the little details and the design
and or should I be allocating that time
to getting us to Mars I should probably
do the latter so you know like what's
more important Mars or a house I like
Mars okay
[Applause]